so last week utilita energy was listed
amongst the top five companies failing
vulnerable customers off gem told the
company it had to do more to help those
who are struggling to pay their bills
and the company's founder and CEO Bill
Bullen joins me now and a billboard and
I want to talk to you a little bit more
about off John's off terms criticisms in
a moment but first of all I want to get
your sense of what you believe the scale
of the issue is at National energy
action is warning that millions of
people could be pushed into fuel poverty
this winter what's your assessment
well we um we accept uh Adam's nea's
numbers on that you know eight and a
half million people in fuel poverty in
this country in the 21st century is a
terrible indictment on where we are um
fuel poverty is driven by three factors
it's driven by obviously price and
that's not helping us at the moment it's
also driven by consumption and also
incomes and you know with inflation
racing away at the way it is you know
people need to recognize that for
low-income household that effective rate
of inflation is even higher because all
the basics like energy like food are
actually
um or what driving that average level of
inflation but they are obviously a
bigger part of the purchasing basket if
you like of lower income households who
you've got a real problem right now
we've got a real problem and you're
being criticized by offgem for not
helping with this problem at all you've
been named and shamed as one of the uh
five worst suppliers for not doing
enough to help vulnerable customers
well first of all I you know it we do an
awful lot to help vulnerable customers
um let me make that absolutely clear
um you know utilita has you know brought
an awful lot of innovation into
especially the smart pre-pace base
um you know trying to bring down the
cost of prepay but also trying to you
know drive up the service that people
get to keep people on Supply with you
know Innovations like power up and also
with autopay so as you know customers
are running down the credit on the meter
they don't disconnect because you know
we've brought an awful lot of innovation
to this market and so we fundamentally
do not accept off gems criticism of us
often have criticized Us in the past
about you know other factors where
they've been frankly way off Target
we're not happy about it
um we are in discussion with them and
you know we hope to be able to resolve
the issues that they've got
but yes because it isn't just what the
one time as you say you have been
repeatedly told off you're accused of
severe weaknesses in July and September
too so you saying that every time it's
the regulator no I'm not saying it every
time and obviously we're not perfect but
you know let's talk about the direct
debit issued off gem earlier this year
issued a press notice that said
something like after the 50 increase in
prices in April something like 500 000
customers have seen a greater than 100
percent increase in their direct debit
of those 500 000 three of them were
utility customers and one of those I
know for a fact was a customer who's
directed it went from about five pounds
to about 20 pounds
so the fact that off gem you know with
their own subjective analysis ignored
the objective analysis that said
actually utilities not part of this
problem they published a press release
that said we were one of the worst
offenders we clearly weren't even by
their own analysis we clearly were not
one of the worst offenders
and yet you'd think that often would
understand all those different
intricacies of the market wouldn't you
I think you know we do have a problem
you know with off gem just not joining
up the dots in its own policies right
now I mean you know this current
accusation that we're not doing enough
to help vulnerable customers as I say
you know utiliters are invaded hugely in
this area
um and you know but we have to operate
under the off-gen price Gap and the
price Gap is causing us to lose money at
the moment off-chem at the same time
keeps increasing the service standards
and the extra Services they want
suppliers to provide to customers all of
which cost money
so you know how do I trying to run a
commercial organization join up this
thoughts the Dots here
um you know there is a clear discrepancy
between whatever often wants us to
deliver and the funding that they're
prepared to give us now I'm not
suggesting that prices should go up for
uh prepaid households in fact I'm very
much in favor of prepay households um
getting the same prices as direct debit
customers but that difference in cost
needs to be addressed somehow and you
know off-gen as I say need to join up
the dots in their own policies here
because they're asking me to you know
complete mission impossible at the
moment
well we'll be interested to see what
often say to what you've said but
there'll be a lot of people watching who
are worried about their bills and and
they'll feel uncomfortable when hearing
that people worrying about making
profits when they can't scrape together
enough cash to pay their bills is there
a problem here that it's an essential
service that people need and companies
are trying to make profits at a time of
crisis
well first of all we're not trying to
make a profit we just quite like to
break even if that's okay there are
companies that clearly are making a
profit out of the current situation and
I think again though you know one of
those issues it comes down to regulatory
policy and actually
badly stated regulations that are
resulting in some generators in
particular making huge profits at the
moment but that's not the supply company
that's not my company we're you know
we're just the retailer um with the you
know customer facing job
um there are people making money further
Upstream but it's not us and you know
it's us that are always in the firing
line
um and it's us that are getting price
capped and it's us that's losing money
well although a lot of energy companies
have been criticized and you're in the
company of others as well aren't you but
so Bill Bill and we do appreciate your
time thanks very much indeed for talking
to us from utilita thank you